WWE 2k23 is the follow-up to last year's
successful relaunch of the wrestling
game franchise which took a year off
after the disastrous WWE 2k20 with 2K 23
2K Games and developer visual concepts
are hoping to build upon the solid
foundation laid by last year's title the
new game features John Cena as the cover
star and the primary focus of this
year's showcase mode with the incredibly
complicated War Games match time being
added to a WWE game for the first time
Gamespot got to play an early build of
WWE 2k23 with all of the focus being on
a limited view of showcase mode a
partial roster and the introduction of
War games and even though explaining the
rules of War Games is a bit of an
undertaking it's a brand new match type
that is easy to figure out once the bell
rings
into the cage now and the numbers
Advantage is locked in the war games
match type is incredibly chaotic and can
be hard to follow at times much like the
real product itself it is made up of two
three or four man teams depending on
what you choose we only had access to
3v3 two opposing wrestlers start the
battle inside two rings which are
encased in a steel cage and one by one
members of each team are released from
cages in the crowd momentum swings back
and forth as one team gets the advantage
over the other and team members make
their way to the ring no one can win the
match however until every member of each
team has entered the war games bout yes
it's exceptionally convoluted as far as
rules go but luckily an intro scene
before the match breaks down everything
for you the match type is a breath of
fresh air for a franchise that's needed
something special to keep up with the
television product once you embrace the
art take chaos within the confines of
two wrestling rings enclosed in a cage
the match type is one of the most fun
and Innovative things 2k games has done
with the franchise in years the trench
the area between the two rings is a
confined space your wrestlers can find
themselves in from time to time but
unlike The Limited area of movement in
Hell in a Cell matches you have a much
Fuller range of movement in the trench
so it doesn't have a No Man's Land feel
you can and it should fight in this area
as you'll want to use the entirety of
the brawling space available outside of
the chaos the first thing WWE fans will
notice is that war games has a different
presentation compared to the live TV
product typically the wrestlers who
haven't entered the battle wait for
their chance to come out in shark cages
which tend to be at the top of the
entrance ramp WWE 2k23 puts these
wrestlers in cages in the middle of the
section behind the ring complete with
stairs for them to walk down so players
can always see the other member members
of that team awaiting their chance to
get involved in war games from the build
we played War Games works it's something
we were skeptical of because the real
life version is an exciting match type
but one that can be hard to follow sure
WWE 2K 23's version is also somewhat
hard to follow at times but that works
given how chaotic the match is meant to
be yes you're primarily taking on one
person at a time but you also have to be
mindful of the rest of your members of
your team in case you have to break up a
pinful or submission then there are two
rings so you can separate from the other
people in order to have more time to pin
someone but in doing so you put distance
between yourself and other members of
the team making it tougher to break up
pins there are tough decisions to make
and that's what makes this such an
exciting and at times
anxiety-inducing match type but it's
gonna do a lot of damage
if you're on the opposite side of this
entry you are racing for a fight much
like previous installments of the game
showcase this time featuring John Cena
opens with the Superstar at a microphone
narrating the highlights of his career
interspersed with archived WWE footage
the introduction sets the stage for a
bit of a spin on the classic game mode
starring the previously mentioned cover
superstar John Cena The Twist is that
unlike previous incarnations of showcase
you aren't playing as Cena match after
match instead you play the role of the
opponents that have beaten him over the
years so those on the Cena sucks
spectrum of the polarizing Cena chants
get to Live Your Dream you follow major
moments in Cena's career playing as
everyone else while the kavistan
narrates the battle this was a step in
the right direction as far as showcase
mode goes as playing as different
characters each match was incredibly
refreshing compared to previous games
while WWE 2k22 showcase mode was fine as
the presentation was nice playing as Rey
Mysterio over and over again became
tedious and so many of Mysterio's
matches didn't have the impact to make
that ear showcase mode a big success
things seem to be improving with 2k23 as
it is refreshing to play the game as
seen as opponents spending time working
on specific objectives in order to
unlock different Arenas championship
titles and even wrestlers there's even
more incentive to play through the
entire showcase mode this year we
noticed that some of the things you
unlock by completing specific challenges
won't actually be accessible until you
complete showcase mode as a whole yes
this is a tad frustrating but it is an
incentive to get through the entirety of
the mode and play through to the end
foreign
new gameplay element in 2k23 is how you
kick out of pinfalls you can use the
traditional pound to the buttons until
your fingers fall off way one which
wrestling games have clung to for the
longest time or you can select a new
variation of this in which a bar pops up
on the screen and there's a smaller Red
Bar moving back and forth which you must
line up with your cursor and then flick
up on the right control stick it's
different and gives a nice accessibility
option for those who either aren't great
at button mashing or may not be capable
of doing so you can now taunt while
holding a weapon something new for the
series some characters got brand new
models like Cody Rhodes and 2006 RVD who
both look brilliant and others look like
they haven't changed much since last
year like Roman Reigns there are lots of
new animations this year and because of
this gameplay seems a bit smoother
compared to last year's game which in
itself was a much needed upgrade from
previous incarnations of the long-lived
series The gameplay felt more fluid and
quick and yes there were a few minor
glitches here and there like hair
clipping through people's shoulders and
the one time we saw someone teleport
from the middle of the Ring to the
outside of the Ring causing their own
elimination in a 10-person Royal Rumble
match but overall everything felt a bit
more smooth and Polished the HUD for
your play is a bit clearer and easier to
read as it got a minor aesthetic update
the finisher bar has three separate
sections so it's even more apparent how
many finishes you have even though that
was never really an issue regardless the
new design is an improvement although we
did notice that the upper deck of the
Arena had no one in it during our time
with the game I'll look at WWE 2k23 was
very limited compared to what we will
eventually see as we were given access
to two modes of play and when its
release is in full we'll see additional
modes like my GM my faction my rise
universe and The Creation Suite 2k's WWE
games are exceptionally large and offer
a variety of different modes to play
however from what we saw WWE 2k23 is
taking the foundation laid down by 2k22
and being built upon in the window the
team has to produce a new game War Games
plays much better than expected and will
undoubtedly be the highlight addition to
this year's game the changes in showcase
mode are all for the better and
eliminate the sluggish playthrough this
feels like yet another step in the right
direction for the WWE 2K Games
foreign